it's important for us to for the United
States to play a major role talking
about the African sting well it's the
U.S aircraft it's the U.S Foreigner so
in spite the fact that our friends the
Allies they're ready to support us but
the aircrafts originally belonged to the
United States but today I've heard
powerful support from many countries and
what's even more important I've heard
about a significant number of
aircraft Fighters and surely under the
leadership of United States will combine
the countries that will create this
Coalition the third aspect that you've
mentioned about NATO it wasn't about
NATO that we had the meeting but Ukraine
has raised this matter because we
believe this is a part of the defense
for the continent and the whole world we
have to do as much as possible for
Ukraine to receive
um a some step forward we're towards the
alliance and we have to receive this
signal from the NATO member nations
we're working on that thank you
Mr President we're happy to welcome you
in Moldova and we surely hope are you
from Moldova
oh yes
your language looks very much similar to
Ukrainian we hope that the war will end
very soon with the victory of Ukraine to
form a patriotic Coalition which role it
will play in the region and for Republic
of Moldova specifically thank you
thank you
charm
I think
whenever we're talking about the
establishment of those coalitions it's
important that the security should be
there not only for the territory of
Ukraine but in this case there won't be
a Safety and Security for the
neighboring countries those countries
who share the same future in the
European Union and I believe that
although we'll go shoulder to shoulder
with Ukraine and Ukraine will do
everything to support moldovan this is
true many uh stamps that we have already
made
on our way to the European Union I'm
confident that our experiences will be
shared with our partners and Moldova in
particular with people of moldala and
with Moldova that supports the policy of
uh of European integration of wires
because I know that there are different
moods in different countries but I
believe that Maya has selected the the
right steps and will be supporting that
as much as possible as for our security
matters whenever we're talking about the
Coalition of uh the fighters or Patriots
or whenever we're talking about error
defense we have to realize what the war
is what the consequences are so whenever
the missiles are being shown by Russia
then those missiles could be landing in
Belarus and Poland and Moldova and many
other countries and this is happening we
have to be friends and unfortunately
there will be more cases if there will
be more missiles and God forbade that
would result in any casualties or
suffering because we clearly understand
the true meaning of that so everyone has
to be interested in the security
situation in Ukraine because it has an
impact on the neighbors
um okay do we have Mike in the audience
okay we don't so next question from here
good evening Mr President
in your speech today at the UPC from
Republic of Moldova you touched the
various sensitive subjects of our
country the transitional transistorial
problem so in our media and also in the
Ukrainian media there are a lot there
are a lot of opinions of experts about
the fact that if moldovian authorities
ask the help of Ukraine veterans history
a conflict can be resolved by a military
solution from different points of use
and circumstances Moldova is not ready
to resolve his problem yet my question
is is the Ukraine already or is it
possible to work out the issue or create
a peaceful way of taking out the Russian
content from moldovian territory to the
way of a black sea thank you Jack
I think we all do need
a United
United Moldova Society in United your
country and of course we wish you only
peace and to do it without
without rules without artillery without
bombs without rockets and Etc it means
without death that's on your land and of
course we'll we'll do our best what we
can and we'll always support you
please trust me I'm sure I'm sure really
that that is it's not fantastic I'm sure
it was you know it's like example that
will never be in Ukraine
our Western Partners will never unite
will never give us modern Western kind
of artillery but we see the result we
did it we United countries I'm happy
that we have United Europe and not only
Europe and that is why I I'm not hope I
I sure
I'm sure on that after we will win and
I'm sure we will
you will you will have United Country
without Rockets
and without Russia
Islam thank you